hey guys Pete here it's going to be my
Game of Thrones Season seven episode 5
top moments recap quick look at all the
biggest moments in this episode and
there were quite a few especially for a
transitional episode I would say if you
haven't watched episode 5 yet then there
will be spoilers in this so this is your
warning so first of all we found out
what happened with Jamie and how he
lived on helped him out of the water and
we found out that he won't be a captive
and he won't see Tyrion he'll just
wander off away from the battle because
they ended up downstream we got to bend
the knee speech that we saw in the
trailer from Daenerys to the captured
soldiers and it was a lot more
reasonable than the trailer made it out
to be we found out that she not only
said bend the knee or die but she made a
point that she wants to break the wheel
making the world a better place that she
knows that Cersei told them that she
wants to come and burn them alive and
all that kind of stuff but that's really
Cersei that's not her a lot of them
decide to kneel right away but Randall
and Dicky and Tarly both are still
standing she pulls Randall up gives him
a chance he calls her a foreign invader
and so she has an army of savages and
pretty much cast his lot in that fashion
the way he lived you could say and
ticken decides that he's going to go
along for the ride as well and that's
just how it goes
she has drove on burn them to death the
rest of their men kneel and that is that
no more [ __ ] in Randall Jaime returns
until Cersei the bad news about how many
people that they lost he also tells her
about Elena being the one who killed
Joffrey not Tyrion she kind of dogs them
a little bit but not much else happens
right here back at Dragonstone we see
the dragon land and Jon just straight-up
touches it it's one of those scenes like
you know it's cool but like why did he
do that so yeah it was it was it was
awesome you know ii mean we kind of all
thought that this might happen but it
just seemed really weird how it went
down anyways of course Daenerys likes
that she might be thinking hey he likes
kids even but you know whatever he
touches the dragon the dragon doesn't
mind it one bit before they can talk too
much though George shows up he's back
you ask them if he's cured he said of
course he is or else he wouldn't have
returned he gets a little hug there and
John might look a little bit salty here
on the side I'm not sure but it almost
looks like he's like oh hey who's this
guy so we see brand skin changing the
Ravens and it's a really cool scene as
he goes out above across east watch over
the wall and we see that the night king
and his army are right there he comes
out of it and tells maester wolkan I
need to send Ravens this leads over to
the Citadel where Sam overhears them
talking about the Raven from wolken and
it's a pretty good scene all the way
around I mean it's kind of convenient
that he just happened to be there when
they were talking about it but he throws
this to sense and they don't really
listen you wouldn't expect that they
would and they almost justify it in a
way you know what I mean like when that
you know they sort of bring up some
other examples in history where people
said this was going to happen or that
was going to happen and it does sound
pretty absurd when you think about it
that a crippled kid in the north saw a
vision through a raven of the night King
marching the you know you kind of see
them with air quotes say the night King
kind of thing but they don't necessarily
believe in but they are going to inquire
again with the maester up at Winterfell
just a case we do see Tyrion and bears
have their conversation they are talking
about Daenerys Varys is imploring him to
get her to listen they point out that
she's not her father but there's kind of
a yet attached to that like she's not
her father yet so they have some concern
we also see that the raven has arrived
with brand's message they all meet up in
the math room which we saw in the
trailer
dawn explains what's going on up there
and tyrion is the one who comes up with
the idea of bringing a white back from
the north to convince Cersei that this
is a real thing that's going on Jorah
immediately volunteers to go and bring a
white back and john says that he has to
go because he's the one who knows what's
going on he's fought with the whites and
the White Walkers
tenaris us a little bit defensive here
or I guess possessive would be the right
where she says I have not given you
permission to leave yet
and that's the first tension that we see
there about the whole situation but in
the end the plan is made Davos throws in
that he can smuggle Tyrion into King's
Landing
to talk to Jaime and access everything
in motion for the trip to Eastwatch at
Winterfell they concede that the
northern Lords and yon royce are losing
faith in Jon being gone there in ting
this also might be a better choice
Arya walks in during this and it's kind
of just watching to see what will happen
when Santa says that jon is the king in
the north and she's behind him that
seems to perk Arya up but then they have
a conversation where she thinks that she
should be a little bit more firm in
supporting Jon after that Tyrion and
Davos land on King's Landing Jaime's led
downstairs by Bronn where they have a
heartfelt meeting they start to get into
things a little bit but Jamie cuts it
off so he tells them that Dany has a
request basically an armistice and they
want to bring the white down to show
them what's really going on up north of
course whether this is something that
they're interested in or not an
armistice is a good thing for them since
they have real fear that the dragons are
going to come to King's Landing and burn
everything down
well Tyrion is doing that almost went to
flea bottom and he runs into Gendry that
was a big reveal that he's been there
the whole time it was planned that way
and gets what Gendry is ready to leave
he just drops everything and goes to all
those drops that I thought you might
still be rowing and it's fanservice but
it's still pretty awesome we see the
Warhammer it's pretty tough looking down
at the beach they run into some gold
cloaks and we can see the Davos still
has it as far as his smuggling ways go
he stalks them out of looking too
closely at anything that's going on pays
them off a little bit and then Tyrion
has the worst timing ever as he comes
down to the beach at the very same
moment they realized that he's probably
the dwarf that they had been looking for
that he's probably carrying Lannister
and this gives a perfect opportunity for
Gentry to unleash the hammer in all its
glory
Jamie goes until Cersei about the
meeting with Tyrion she says do you
think anything happens here without me
knowing she asked that he's going to
punish Bronn for what he did and then we
find out she's pregnant there's some
controversy over whether this is really
happening or not I think she probably is
Qyburn was there he was asking if she
wanted something that would probably be
moon tea I would imagine so this could
have been her plan all along like I said
we saw her get with him right after the
sand snakes thing and if she's expecting
that she's gonna have to marry you're on
to keep her end of the bargain up then
it would make sense that she would want
to be with child but Jamie's child
specifically before all that went down
they embrace we hear the saying the lion
does not concern himself with the
thoughts of the sheep which is cool and
everything seems to be okay at that time
Gentry tells Jon who he is right away as
soon as they meet him after a long
conversation with Davos saying not to do
that they have some serious bastard
bonding and it's pretty cool when you
think about it I mean this is Robert
Baratheon bastard and for all intents
and purposes Ned Stark's bastard so it's
cool to see those two and there's a
little bromance brewing I would think
Jorah and Tyrion has their reunion and
Tyrion gives him a coin the coin that
the slavers gave them and then we get to
goodbye and there was pretty heavy I
would say and you could definitely tell
Daenerys has some feelings brewing you
could see something a little bit of
something in John but it's especially
emphasized in Daenerys like there
there's no question anymore these two
are going to be a couple so we're over
at the Citadel and Sam and Gilly are
there and Sam's upset because the
maester the arch maesters won't listen
to them and Gilly just casually reads
that the Septon had annulled the Rhaegar
Targaryen marriage and performed a new
wedding with Leon a stark so this is
like the hugest reveal of all time
basically not only was our plot
they'll equals J true which we got last
season but this is the fact that they
were actually married so John is Ray
gars legitimate heir now that does make
his claim better than Daenerys as though
there's no reason to really go into that
right at this moment the big thing is is
that Sam isn't paying attention and it
basically goes unnoticed not to worry
though he gave the book to baby Sam so
even though they leave a short time
afterwards the book is coming along with
them before he decides to take off
though he breaks bag goes in takes a
bunch of books and they cut out leaving
the Citadel behind arya is spying on
Littlefinger and she breaks into his
room after seeing maester wolkan give
him a scroll and we find out that it's
actually a setup because he's waiting
outside now that scroll is the letter
that Sansa wrote well I should say the
letter that Santa sent she didn't
actually write it Cersei he basically
wrote it but it's telling Rob to bend
the knee because you know father's been
killed for treason it's that letter so
in some levels this could piss Arya off
so I'm not sure it'll work a hundred
percent because arya was there like she
sort of knows what the situation was so
it may not be as effective as
Littlefinger thinks it is but at the
same time you're watching arias file and
him thinking that she's got something
going on but it's all a setup by him so
he hasn't lost his touch either after
that they just arrived at Eastwatch -
they're there they meet tormund he asks
how many men they brought they say -
whew he asks about Barry Ann which is
pretty funny and we find out that the
Hound is there with the Brotherhood and
they're locked up so their game to come
along as well kind of a cool scene when
you think about it because there are a
lot of different interest inside these
this little group here but John
correctly points out that they're all on
the same side because they're a lot so
you know barrack and Thoros have their
reasoning for one ago the hounds had his
vision John needs a white because he
needs to show everyone down south what's
really going on ginjuries just there for
the party he just has to be out of
King's Landing
yeah so you know I mean that you know
there's a lot of people that wouldn't
get them all in otherwise but they're
all there to make up one of the most
all-star kind of teams that I've ever
seen really if you think about this I
mean this is a pretty cool lineup by any
way you want to look at it I mean I want
these guys on my side for sure and the
whole thing ends up with them walking
out of the gate going out beyond the
wall and like I said this is a
cool-looking squad I did the trailer
breakdown earlier and we you know we've
seen a bunch of this stuff already from
the winter is here trailer so we know
what to expect in the next episode and
it's going to be pretty epic
so yeah the big things here are
obviously Jon touch drogon I mean and he
didn't burn him he didn't do anything he
was happy to be touched so that's going
to go a long way to connecting him with
Daenerys I mean even if there wasn't
this romance that's budding
as far as believing him I mean I would
think that that would be a big thing you
know if your dragon doesn't mind him
touching him he's probably a trustable
guy right
also the reveal did break our Lyanna
were married I mean this has been
speculated about pretty much forever was
it a kidnapping and a rate or did they
run away together
apparently I mean he was the Crown
Prince but apparently there may have
been another reason that the annulment
was okay perhaps his wife couldn't have
any more children and he was really
obsessed with the prophecy and the
dragon having three heads so maybe that
was his reasoning was you have to let me
marry someone else so I can have another
rightful son or daughter I guess it
really wouldn't matter but so he could
have three children but yeah that is
that's confirmed now Sam has left a
citadel he's headed north you're going
to guess that he's headed to Winterfell
that piece of paper will probably show
up but it's still kind of funny that
Gilly just happened to read it in this
really boring
ceptin diary like where he kept track of
everything all this stuff no one would
ever really want to read through and
it's good I mean I guess that's kind of
the point they're making is how it could
have stayed hidden for so long but yeah
so that's there and everything's heading
to the north obviously some tensions are
going to be building back at Winterfell
but yeah I think it was a pretty good
episode there you know things are moving
way too fast for my
tastehh but it wasn't unwatchable it
wasn't so bad that I could really
complain about it I just think that it
could be longer but whatever we're
finding a lot of stuff out things are
moving towards this big battle next week
and then after that we're going to find
out how the rest of the kingdom responds
when they realize that the white Walker
threat is actually real so please like
this video if you enjoyed it please make
sure you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already make sure you let me
know in the comments what you saw this
what you're expecting to see coming up
was it too fast there's only two
episodes left now so at least they're
longer ones right please follow me on
Twitter and my other social media
accounts thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon